hello everyone welcome to another
episode of red lips orange car my name
is Alana PS and before we get into the
episode today I just wanted to apologize
for some of the audio issues we have in
the first three episodes they do get
fixed after this one it's basically just
me you know being new to a podcast
trying to figure out how to edit audio
how the mic setups works so I'm aware
that the levels are a little bit off and
it does improve in future episodes so
thank you for sticking with us in the
early stages of the show while we're
still figuring all of that stuff out now
to the episode I'm joined today by Monty
sleeve oh and Joey pneumo
okay hi Joey where are you from / kind
of innoGames corner thank you for
joining us today thanks for inviting me
this is super fun I'm sitting on my
floor it's like Dawn of us dated yeah
this is we've kind of like spoken about
this like so I kind of like the idea
that every episode of this podcast is
recorded on a floor somewhere and one of
the upcoming guests was like you can use
my studio if you want there's like man
like what if we did it on the bed oh
this is a black house what we talked
about misconnections motion yes is that
really surprising no but I guess I just
never really thought about it yeah
what's that I'm fancy - connection is
from the peninsula in the Bay Area and
its title is balloons misty balloon
emoji
excellent okay there's a man single
woman Pennywise legitimately Oh sibling
okay it says so I'm just a guy that's a
sucker for a women surrounded by
balloons okay well wing them up popping
them balloon animals dancing kicking
throwing them around balloon costume
winky face
what's that balloon costume okay again
cos u winky face and anything's simple
innocent fun involving you and I and
balloons this could be ongoing or a
one-time situation no pressure
except you mean like pressure - all
right okay no naughty and no pressure no
naughty no gimmicks sort of thing
30 Caucasian five six considerate
competent not a fluke I am real kindly
bought your favorite color bulletins in
the subject line let's chat but most of
all let's keep it silly and
light-hearted okay so this is a man who
would like to have a non-sexual hangout
involving bullets balloons it's just a
sucker for a woman and balloons how do
you how do you get a woman in balloons
well you know the slime on guys
yeah so they have videos where they like
it was in a balloon and they filled it
up
we always like underneath it at one
point and then they fill it up and then
they like pop it in slow-mo so like
maybe it's a fanzine from the slow mo
guys they suckers for women and balloons
probably yeah that seems like a thing
that they would be into for slo-mo
purposes sure do they find their yeah
they do so okay so this is clearly a
fish shape it's yeah but if he says no
I'm sexual oh yeah yeah okay can you
have a known sexual fetish fetish all
right yeah but you could just really
like something does that make it a
fetish I like I like I like the smell of
gas stations like I like the smell of
petrol I guess that's pretty weird yeah
but I don't like go to gas station is
that the same as like I really like dogs
I would probably put listening post up
and be like hey just looking for people
who have multiple dogs to hang out with
nothing sexual what kind of dog do you
have
okay now I'm on boy
now that we put it in those times like
there's like somewhat of a reciprocal
relationship with dogs of like you get
something back the balloons can't
consume yeah some weird he really likes
safe sex and gondola spa thing but then
he talks about a lot of different types
of balloons and I was like maybe that's
so he talks about a couple things which
are like actual acts with
he says blowing them up that's a
bullying thing popping balloons a
balloon animal
dancing that's not good that's just
dancing that's right okay and then he
says kicking throwing them around and
then balloon costume what's that we have
to dressing up as creeps that's some
Lady Gaga [ __ ] but maybe he like this is
like a subliminal subliminal Zonk very
what it's like an undercover way to find
a girl who's dressed up in balloon
costumes would you like doesn't want to
be super forward about it cuz he's like
feels weird about this balloon fetish
it's like hey just in general yeah this
like a gateway to like just full latex
suit you know it's just out no pressure
no doggy no gimmicks yeah but is that
how he gets you know that's okay but if
you're gonna post on Craigslist or and
it's sexual why wouldn't you just say
hey blatantly a fetish hey come on these
balloons yeah okay
hi I want us to have balloon sex serious
it would is balloon says how do you I
filled the balloons create space and
that creates like trouble and then
balloons pop that's exciting and then
make a weird noise no one gets on to
heart no I don't things exciting yeah
it's like if you have sex in the morning
and you have much morning like alarm set
and that's just annoying that one goes
off well what do we just never happen to
me that's morning like 10 well like I
have to have so many set yeah it's we
lean on behalf of Mila maybe I'm one
weekends and that's that's that's why
you were late for Jared do I said
whatever we can yeah really yeah I
showed up to brunch with Jared for the
last episode of okay
side note what happened there was that I
was like hey Monty organised brunch on
Friday and then you organized brunch
when I was already asleep is when you
texted the time to have brunch I was
already asleep
I fell asleep you're like oh I showed up
to brunch yeah cuz you texted her when I
was asleep in your away doesn't count
alright I don't have any comments on
this but we need to give this man a name
mmm does he have a name uh I like
balloon berry I'm gonna open that up
blueberries pretty good bluey Joey no I
don't like that the theme makes sense um
look I have almost nothing of value to
comment on this one because I'm so
confused I just have a lot of questions
go on let the way I was about this one
you - I guess I would be confused as to
why you would post this on Craigslist if
it's not a fetish yeah I feel like
inherently miss connections are
generally sexual could it be a dude who
is like totally aroused by weird balloon
[ __ ] but doesn't want to admit that or
like hasn't admitted it to himself so
he's like hey not weird totally normal
thing about most people just want to
hang out dance
balloons it's cool dancing doesn't
really balloon costume but it like is a
fetish thing that he's just like how
many times with how do you even get a
finish like that no ooh are we getting
into a nature versus nurture debate I
think a lot of edges are chemical and I
think some are experiential like why do
I like the smell of yeah you keep saying
that it's very convinced it's all the
since we're like by the mere fact if
you're like I've never killed anybody
yes it's you killed someone yeah it
really does
yeah your strong point about Megan but
which means never definitely not a
fetish I've like the smell of gas since
before and I masturbated why did I say
that
anyways I think there's a ninja thing or
nature yeah I guess I've never thought
about it being like a chemical thing I
think certain things are just inherent
yeah right well don't I mean my sexual
interest of change like dramatically as
I've gotten older I don't think it's
yeah I wasn't like all right had sex
the first time here's what I'm into like
I'm not saying it's fully chemical but I
think that's part of it well I'm sure it
has a option to be a factor but I don't
think that you are born with a fetish
you think that you were born
liking the smell of gas stations it's
not like I go inside we had sweaty man
behind the high school dropouts I know I
just want to talk to a balloon Berry but
not respond to his message I'm just I
just follow up questions yeah blueberry
were his friends no employees do it but
this one's quite I'm quite stumped I'm
quite stumped by this you use the emoji
well as if you started it with a red
balloon emoji well there's also a clown
no there's no I mean I feel like a cute
thing here would have been a nod to
clearly red balloons have become more
popular in the last year yeah like the
80s it was very different contexts very
that was about warning people of
impending war do you think that he
enjoys do you think that he plays 99 red
balloons during these encounters
doubtedly please have bad sound that's
in the it trailer they're like I like I
like the idea that it's a knit fetish
moment but he he has a fetish for penny
wise things that he is dressed up as a
clown know when these girls he's dressed
up as the kids yeah and then it's that
he wants someone else to be penny wise
and he's easing him into it by being
like hey this isn't sexual I just need
you to like hold some balloons maybe you
could dance did you do is stand there
dance for me and I'll float to
okay I don't know if that if I'm
relieved by this situation that we have
more answers or if I just now I'm
relieved a minute makes slightly more
sense to me
yeah than it did before I still think
also well you know nobody's there fetish
yeah it does he also the clown fetish
those can go in a separate variable yeah
church and state yeah just like the
church in the state you just know just
like I like the smell of gas but gas
stations like that definitely never
masturbated either of those what's the
next one what if there's a new topic
okay Joey it's been here well it's not a
fidget spinner it's a pop stockade okay
so I found one on the San Francisco
Craigslist mhm do we read the titles
yeah yeah okay so it says to the lady
next to me on the SFO flight sitting
next to you for hours with little to no
personal states space separating us
affected more affected I've seen he
meant me more than you know
yes I notice when your leg accidentally
brushed against mine
the whole time I just wanted to get
something out but held back because you
are too much of a lady it's not like
butterflies or knots getting off the
plane was bittersweet relief you see I
really interesting is this a dude who
wrote a poem and then just published it
on Craigslist maybe I mean it is it real
yeah no I mean like is it is he trying
to find someone or is this just a man
who is like she's like look at my
greatest work let me publish this I
don't know hmm I can't died I like the
three act structure of this did you
leave a way to contact him or anything
like that no name hmm
he didn't describe her at all no I like
that I was I took my glasses off
initially because why I'm uncomfortable
with the way his story's going I take my
yeah because if I can't see what's going
on it can't hurt me can I do this one
I'm uncomfortable and I'm like cuz I he
was like your light touched mine thus
there was chemistry I'm like hey that's
a [ __ ] flight okay but there's also
sometimes something if someone like puts
both of their legs like that like very
much in my space like it's pause my arm
chat I will aggressively like put my leg
back like itch give me my first yeah
yeah like hold on and they could be like
oh you touched my leg I'm like I'm just
telling you to get the [ __ ] out of my
space and then all he needed to do was
fart that's how I mean that's how you or
a titular misconnection it me but I like
that it was initially like hey the
state's creepy and I was then I was like
why didn't he talk to her like you were
saying next to her like you really want
to check out the conversation you could
have turned out he said so I have one
story about I was writing on my phone
and I was sitting next to the window and
the two seats next to me were completely
empty and I was just writing like a
preview of something flying back from
event it was like I was walking and the
flight attendant came up to my row and
like at one point asked me what I was
writing it was like oh it's for walk and
then he like walked off came back later
and then sat in the aisle seat and just
asked me a lot of questions
meaning that he was like he works now
and I don't but he had boxed me in to
where I was sitting I couldn't get out
or really politely tell him to leave and
he at no point asked if he was okay to
sit there he just sat next to me while
I'm walking and started asking me
questions and I was like okay well like
he was fine like he was like a perfectly
polite dude and it wasn't an
uncomfortable conversation it was like
if I was uncomfortable with this what
the [ __ ] would I do and I think that's a
bad thing on a flight is like you can't
leave like I always think about this
[ __ ] that way is like if I can't leave
and I have no good way to exit or you
haven't presented me with a way to exit
from the very beginning but it's like
gonna be another or you haven't opted
into the conversation right like if he
had been like hey can I sit here then
that would have been I probably would
have said yes and it would have been
fine
I'm not asking means like okay I'm
automatically like well I'm [ __ ]
yeah it's like we talked about right but
how like if you were driving in
someone's car and there
your driver and they start saying [ __ ]
like that but you did not opt into that
and you don't have a way to get out not
leavin they know you let's run away from
a red light I guess pretty weird yeah
super weird yeah but that I get for
floating on people with planes I don't
know I think you're probably fine to
have like a flowy conversation with the
person sitting next to you and just like
take the cues if they have the
headphones in if they try to read a book
like they're probably trying to exit
yeah but it's not a transportation like
yes that's the same in the gym yeah I've
only had that's different one flight
wherever I should talk to a stranger
that's me
and she was lonely sports with the
conversation and then they get to our
flight home I have a bunch of times and
actually they've all been positive like
all the interactions have been totally
fine I never want to sign a stock
conversation exactly which I mean
they've all been older people actually
mostly older women oh yeah so what are
you doing young go tell me about your
life that you're older women in Russia
what are you doing young girl like I've
only ever had one battle interaction but
it wasn't a like it wasn't a romantic
plane interaction there was a girl that
was sitting next to me on a flight home
it was like one of the first lights out
and she very clearly had like not taken
very many flights mm-hmm she was like
rolling her bag down the middle and like
bumping everyone and she had like her
feet on the seat in front of her and was
very bad classic flight noob right
exactly and I was next the window and I
it was like a six o'clock flight like I
just wanted to go back to bed so I like
had my head against the window and I had
the shade closed and like right before
we started to land she reached over and
flipped to the shade up and we were on
the side of the Sun it was just reaching
a limit everyone she blinded me through
that nickname I like was super startled
and I looked at her and I like
aggressively slammed it down I was like
you can't vomit up and she looked as
super terrifying like and as soon as the
plane
landed and the thing went off she like
popped out and like good immediately
trying to vote for the front yeah that's
a problem I report some airplanes in
general like no weird scenarios it's
clearly unnatural for a human being to
be put in a situation a can like that
and thrust it into there yeah sometimes
feel like fifteen hours yeah never but
like we do that a bunch for what we are
super used to it was like you go on
these flights and seems that people just
lose all like sense of normality and how
many a human being and just like how to
interact with others and how lines work
and how Lions work yeah I mean there's a
bunch of stuff about em what's that
annoys the [ __ ] out of me as someone who
takes flights a lot but that said like
again I think most of my interactions on
planes have been very positive okay but
also that said I can also distinctly
remember the times with someone bothered
really badly on a plane and you're like
alright which [ __ ] did that now
I have to sit with the smell it's going
to be recycled for the next 12 hours Oh
what do I do now that's not great either
so what you're saying is that this this
fart Bart is a hero you've already had
fought but we've absolutely not had fart
Bart yeah we have fart but is already an
existing name and his podcast Cinematic
Universe
it's only been six names and none of
them are far apart well he might have
been shot but man man we can't you
fought bought again it has to be
different I don't [ __ ] Joey what's his
name I'm trying to think
guess we could go with gas but then that
makes me thinking with mati masturbating
[Laughter]
we could do foggy mati that's fine
I want to reiterate I never masturbated
in a gas station but we can call the
other one Chloe Joey and we can call
this one party Marty I'm fine with that
I'm sorry I just wanted him to know that
I've never been I guess definitely never
done that that's yep never have another
way since anymore
I think that this one we have to come
back to this
like this version of like when people
are accused of child molestation they
can't be like within a hundred yards of
a school I can't be yard okay I think I
think this one is made up I think this
is a dude who was like hey I wrote this
really funny show it's Chuck a feeler
out there I don't think it's real
because I think if you wanted to
actually get in touch with someone you
would have mentioned something about
someone something relatively like hey we
touched links on a plane is like that's
not quite enough that's like 90% of
place yeah yeah yeah you're gonna touch
the post the next I'll talk about and he
held his pardon because he desperately
cared about the woman next to him that's
very nice yeah okay
well let him know all right let me pull
mine up which I'm pretty stoked about
this one I actually got from Melbourne
Australia just cuz I wanted to look up
some of the Australian ones and some of
them were very Australian it was
excellent
this one is cold this one is cold wife
needs a massage and then it's very it's
just one sentence hi there the wife
needs a massage so if you have a massage
table and know how to get how to massage
get in contact with us that's all it
says but it is listed as M w4m so a man
and a woman looking hi man and then
Bonnie tuck is listed as curvy so this
seems very innocent this seems like it
is like hey man me watch go to stall
back really needs a massage
I think this dude's look is for some sex
and then you know why would you put
million threesomes
why would you put buddy Covey listed
back if you want like hey my masseuse
need to know and women are looking for a
manual it says MW for M meaning okay and
it's not w-4 and like on behalf of his
wife also like why didn't he could if he
needed a massage she goes to a [ __ ]
masseuse like surely there's websites
for those professionals but not
Craigslist like if you are doing this
seriously and maybe he's like an 70 year
old dude he's like ah Marge told me to
Google
a masseuse and I couldn't find it but
this week's on Craigslist came up and so
he's like on that like I can understand
him being like hey you know how to
massage get an uptick and then it's very
sweet but maybe like it's also like
Kirby is like well I'm you know my wife
has a lot of knots in her back and I
don't want some skinny you can literally
be a person there's no idea what they're
doing on the internet and it's like why
is it asking my body type Oh curvy
because it also has status married in
age 35
is he coming is she coming which one of
them it's coming there's a lot of
unknowns in this one yeah yeah I think
it's it's a secret sex thing but it
doesn't say but em w4m right he's doing
and he's actually just trying it just
says guarantee view google massage
Craigslist isn't gonna be the first
thing that pops up if you're trying in
ER because I'm a I've done some terrible
Google searches in my past and come up
with things that I intentionally
definitely didn't mean to like it's
possible like yeah it would have been
quite difficult but he was like alright
well here we are and I thought it's not
doing hi there the wife needs a massage
so it's just like does he think this is
like an open live forum where someone's
immediately gonna be like hey mate right
like this you think it's gonna be a mean
it's a just as I do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers but it
doesn't say a phone number or anything
like that it just says the northern
suburbs of Melbourne Australia what's
what's what's vulvar like for people who
don't know San Francisco II yeah
Seattle II maybe okay it's like either
of those cities it's very liberal City
but I guess most Raley's probably but
this was like amongst various like hey
really want to suck a dick saw you at
the gym last night like there's like
mountains of those so I thought this one
was bears out when looking for various
Craigslist postings for the show if you
do it
at work or in public you gotta be
careful because men one out of every
senator dick well while I was looking on
the Melbourne one that was like hey like
I'm a dude of this build who's gay
looking to have sex with like straight
bi or gay dudes
here's a picture pictures not of me it's
just to get someone else like but he's
like maybe vaguely like I didn't have a
camera at the time but like what you
might be into I don't know like this is
my plan
yeah I like that I like that it's just
literally the first image search for
dick Australia there's a electronics
store like chain pigs dick Smith yeah
Dave Smith yeah so it'd be like big
deals
Dick's holiday special so everyone in
Australia thinks it's funny they shut
down its critics though in the u.s. yeah
that seems more sexually penises says
yeah bring these materials to the text
before like a level to be thrown take
how do we well I just want you guys I
just want I just want your input on why
do you think this is a genuine listing
of a person looking to [ __ ] or just an
innocent man who's like hey g'day me wax
got a soul back no I think that there's
you think it's sexual oh yeah
do you think bawdy kirby is him or I
think that's what we're looking for
oh so they're looking for a Kirby
mansu's okay with a copy masseuse-man
what says so pervy is a word that i
generally here Sherman into women right
what's pervy man probably like a bad
yeah yeah I feel like it's a good
question he is the tournament Stuckey
yeah maybe you're right
coving man I feel like bears probably
the closest we're gonna get yeah for a
test for that one
that's why I kind of think she's talking
about his wife's potty time but um I
just love the idea that it's a really
old dude he's like my wife and I are
looking for a masseuse I like that Tommy
I guess I am
my wife for me oh I think this one's
excellent it also say age 35 so that
like Ivan rules out my theory in tile
means that they're looking for a 35 year
old very married man masseuse non-sexual
not sexual just wife has a soul back if
you have a massage table and know how to
massage also why would you have a mess
ups table if you don't know how to mess
up get in contact with us well I think
this is like maybe a shared account I
wished it there a way that you could
look at posting histories like you can
and read it yeah like what's every every
single person who's ever posted yeah
like weekly he's like hey out cattle
Brooke if you have a cattle you're not
using like told him that Google is
Craigslist missed connections and so
every dummy type something out he's like
alright so I put it in the Google I
didn't find a kettle everyone's yourself
to another web page we haven't given him
a name massage men well you're any kind
of doesn't what's uh what's like an old
man name
[Laughter]
and blowy Joey uh what this bully man's
actual name very bullying assumption
Maurice is a pretty old dude named yeah
massage Boris no I'm cool with that
don't go with it so who is the most
likely this is the game we play at the
end okay who is the most likely to have
them misconnection be successful I mean
the interesting thing about this is I
wanna mine and yours are directed at a
specific person and yeah this one's an
interesting one or interesting this is
possibly fainted yeah or even if it's
not fixed so we have to let's go with
the assumption that it's fine let's go
on the assumption that it's not fiction
okay to make this game better so it's
like if that I think a massage will have
the best wind chance right I need a
massage he'll audience will also like
this is totally sexual and then they
show up at Morris's house and it's like
oh no we just actually want to know so
much but it's like he's like people
could be into that the whole man for man
and woman for man Kobe 35 married I
disagree I think knowing San Francisco I
think there is a woman out there who is
totally into whatever this balloon [ __ ]
is going on I think there's someone out
there it was like hmm like this boy's
freaky deaky like I want to see what's
going on but it's not naughty
he said no naughty yeah no nobody we
know what the snake said in the Garden
of Eden I think I've never read the
Bible he said dudes don't eat the apple
when you only brought up the snake I was
expecting you to give us like a Harry
Potter basilisk referencing myself a
Bible there um yeah I think that's it's
like the forbidden fruit I think the
enter in a playful way people saying
that when it comes to things like anal
when you say it about hey just want to
dance and pop balloons I don't think
that applies to the forbidden fruit we
think anal is
not sexual forbidden because it's not
forbidden the enticing thing that you're
not supposed to which similar thing is
not anything with helium because what if
a match goes off and blows up entire
apartment that doesn't seem related why
if you want room full of balloons and
you why don't you think there why do you
think he's gonna put helium in them when
they have one that's super heavy so if
you did half in half it's good jacks
that's the really only know God said do
you guys ever when you're a kid hang out
with like a balloon that has scale a
minute and just literally just like
punch it to each other and it like flies
across the room if someone will like hey
Lana
like for a while when I hang out this
weekend like each other I would say yes
yes I would be like yeah look at that I
also dancing yeah no no idea Sean my
house you bought is where it gets weird
sure you say anything about a bedroom
did you know I've seen that yeah a
friend of mine trust that position has a
bunch of grapes and then that popped a
bunch and then she was just Thanks only
animals fancy kicking throwing him
around balloon costume but it says
balloon costume in that a winky face
balloon costume and anything simple
innocent fun involving unit so your
argument you is that yours is more
likely than someone being able to give
someone else a mask
yes to use no way do you know I think
this is the only person in the Bay Area
and was to get his rocks off you think
that no one in Oakland massage table or
one to fund a couple the other we don't
know it applies to fun I think there's
more people who would be into weird
kinky blend stuff than own a massage
table I don't think no I think even
that's wrong I bet no one no no none of
everybody
I bet no one we see on a daily basis
those massage table do you think at
least one person we see on a daily basis
is a
people in trypsin I already have an idea
for who it is though
[Laughter]
so then where does Joey's fit in with 40
money I still think it can never be
because that's cream so I think I'm
really nicely thank you president that
point there you go
age 38 there you go there you go all
right where I left ahem it's been up
Joey's your ranking which one do you put
first first thing is yours yeah and then
Marty's into mine all right
I feel pretty good about that authority
again it's like a stat about the amount
of people who have fawning in any one
given time and it like any time that I
thought about it it makes me
uncomfortable
do you feel like millions also like just
millions of people have erections at any
one point in time it's alright yes don't
like for once more just like that's one
of the stories I was reading when I was
trying to pick this one was also like
hey I was at a urinal in this shopping
center and you had an erection and then
I got one and then we both left dude's
just being with banas and then being
like alright well by trying to find you
again though yeah we will never have to
experience but is always fascinating
yeah what to pee in the urinal you got
an erection I got an erection
alright see in the podcast for the yeah
that would be that I meant I was gonna
tell a story about the thing that I have
what happening the men's bathroom and we
won't do it because it involves an
identifying factor so we'll just keep
that right out of it
all right I think I think we I think we
really saw various mysteries today you
guys good money where can we find you
you can find me on social media at make
biggity with - geez
and then the aforementioned SP and also
a lot of gas stations no you have
allowed to go it that's right you're not
allowed to know first off I can go to
any gas station I did well please second
off I don't have my shirt off I've never
best admitted I guess it mm-hmm
Joey we find you all the social medias
at Joey Noel and occasionally on some of
the youtubes why do they not let you
play games
I just never only campaign content
because they won't let me talk about
persona 5 and it's a goddamn travesty
can we have Joey on beyond to talk about
that story we could absolutely do that
I have thousand person it's like not
really relevant now we saw the donors
one of the guys here there we go oh wait
what's a lot of fishes that will do us
in danger yeah apparently have 7000 is
in that game now Nile accident we left
it on overnight I'm saying I like don't
know I think I have 40 like I don't know
just figure out what palettes you're on
and I feel like that's the easier song
full is that 3d awful for it full my
fault also you can find me at Charl Anza
it's my name in the middle of chars on